mentoring local students and setting  them up for success that is the goal of  a partnership  it's between westgate las vegas and ccsd  current southwest career and tech  academy students met with world-class  culinary and hospitality pros  they got to learn about the industry and  showcase their skills make sure students  are  college and career ready it's really  exciting  because we have like the best of the  best in terms of  like students who have dedicated their  time  and energy into this program and it's  nice to see that  we're working so hard and it's paying  off organizers say events like this  really promote networking opening the  doors for students who might be looking  for a job in the hospitality industry